Hey pour yourself some champagne and
throw on your best Versailles bathrobe
we're about to get into some showgirls
honest trailer commentaries the show
where we watch the show on the other
channel talk about it
give me some jokes that we cut out at
the end if you stick around until then
I'm Spencer Shay Gilbert to my right hi
welcome to the state I was gonna do a
stripper intro oh yes yeah okay
gentlemen if you look to stage right
he'll put this buckle in your sky wish
on a shooting it's just uh I'm here for
the foster kids I'm taking care of what
that's my that's my strippers background
story okay and over here those hot
Hollywood days turn into hot Hollywood
nights it's dead in the met membership
sorry I was doing we're doing the
showgirls strippers elizabeth berkley in
there yeah I was gonna lick the
microphone for a second but I also
kicked the desk really hard when I did
yes guys this movie's a is a cult
classic according to some others it's
just terrible where do you guys fall in
the spectrum I did not get I was like 12
months when we came out so obviously I
had a mom who cared about me so I did
not see this movie when it came out and
I was very I was i own Lee saw it for
the first time a few years ago so I
generally tend to regard it as a pretty
bad movie but I understand why so many
people revere it so much because it is
that kind of like bad where it's hard to
believe it wasn't all accidental some of
it does seem on purpose but yeah I lean
a little bit more towards look it was
just poorly done there Joe but the
production value my god Eileen I lean
towards that this movie might be too
good for this world where you have Paul
Verhoeven who did these brilliant
satires and Robocop and Starship
Troopers and then this one just skates
this weird gray area of you're like I
don't know if you're doing this on
purpose or not man
I don't know it's a fascinating riddle
of a film and I've got a lot of
nostalgia for it because it takes you
back to a time where you would put in
your free trial
AOL CD and spend an hour and a half
trying to download a picture of
Elizabeth Berkeley from this movie yeah
there you go that's that I think that's
the context that I knew it growing up
was like the movie with the full frontal
nudity in it but having grown up and and
watch again you can make the case that
there's more going on you can make the
case that this is a heightened extreme
exaggeration of like the Hollywood like
rags to riches story which it is which
it is I don't know when you add in when
you had in Jo Astor house yeah you add
in the era in which it came out and I
have a hard time believing it was
intended that way it was too extremist
it really should not be collaborating
and Paul Verhoeven and Djoser Hawes both
people who just lay it on incredibly
thick yeah and just pile on pile on pile
on and I don't know if like it maybe if
they were maybe they were going for
something but I don't think it quite
came together the way that they lost
control I think they started that this
is gonna be a satire and at some point
they lost control of it like it became
sentient no longer control where this
movie went I think it might have been
that Paul Verhoeven meant for it to be a
satire and Joe Eszterhas didn't yeah
yeah and just collided in the middle
yeah because there's some really funny
over-the-top moments in this movie and
Elizabeth Berkeley's acting choices like
I have to imagine that's fair hope and
just yelling at her like he do more like
crazier crazier crazier he has said that
he basically sank her career by making
her act like a psychopath on camera
daybed um and then but on the other hand
like there's moments where the movie
either plays it straight or just plays
it like this is intentionally disturbing
and like this is a real drama and you
should you should care about these
characters as characters like like the
the third act like sexual assault scene
at the end everybody's like oh my god
like that's not like a funny like
light-hearted satire or is it am I just
the joke I don't know I don't know yeah
like I said they lost control of yes it
seemed like again I got got away from
him I'm trying to put into context how
strange it is in the time that this
movie came out that elizabeth Berkley
was the star of this movie like this
would be like if someone from like
gnarly icarly yeah exactly
shifted within a couple of years from
doing like you know icarly to playing a
stripper and an nc-17 movie but I mean
there is a time-honored tradition though
of the not child star but like you know
the kid entertainment starving like
growing up yeah but this is maybe the
most extreme it's Britney going from
like oops I did it again too toxic yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't know because it
was supposed to be drew Barrymore
supposed to be Charlize Theron and then
you've got it you've you've got to sort
of put yourself in her shoes and it's
like the guy who literally lost his
genre and a type of cable channel with
Basic Instinct like wants me to be in
this next major thing that's gonna be
huge Sharon Stone got a I think an ask
Oscar nomination I think for a bet for
Basic Instinct but what if not it has
launched her into super Starling yes
Sharon Stone was like the biggest star
in Hollywood off of Basic Instinct so
yeah if you're Elizabeth Berkeley of
course you're gonna say yes to this role
because look at what look at the the the
what just happened but man I agree they
they they they guided her right into a
buzz saw
well let's guide it into our own buzz
saw as we roll the honest trailer for
joke outs wonder if this will be
educated by the time yesterday okay
great
yeah I was demonetised instantly and
maybe it might be educated before fifty
shades of gray before easily accessible
internet porn the sexiest thing you
could see in the screen was probably not
now rubbin on rednecks face we got his
permission me show girls you know it has
a cult classic or does that movie you'd
watch on mute as a kid but in 1995
showgirls was the biggest deal in
Hollywood as the first nc-17 film to get
a wide release pinned by the
highest-paid screenwriter directed by
the guy who made Basic Instinct and hate
it by nearly everyone who is alive at
the time they don't do anything original
in the screenplay at all I didn't care
for the film well I didn't either cause
I think we we tip our hand a little bit
to the audience we were aiming for it
this trailer when we say the movie you
watched on mute when you were a kid
because I would say most of our target
audience not born on that this is so
obviously I think we acknowledge this is
gonna connect more with an older that's
a good point most of our audience was
just being born in perhaps conceived at
a screening of this film that's that's
where I was going just to set the stage
on this a little more like to make it
even funnier how ridiculous this movie
was when it came out it was hugely
protested it was the only entertainment
story leading up to it theater chains
were gonna carry it so they had to do
these like hey it's all gonna be fine
screenings for chain CEOs I remember my
mom like every time the Sunday paper
came in she would just take the
entertainment section out because she
knew it was gonna be an article about
whatever is happening with showgirls and
she would throw it in the trash because
there's a loot photo in the front of it
oh yeah the trash yeah I believe goes to
one place blockbuster which at the time
was like Netflix you don't know
Blockbuster web looks that he walked
inside yeah he walked inside and like
cave and browsed like a peasant you as I
recall I don't think they would carry
the nc-17 version they had an r-rated
version which was heavily edited I think
had like digital bars and stuff like
this was this was a big deal and old
and then this came out yeah
and it was awful yeah it was tough to
find clips contemporary of 1995 but like
this just got roasted by everyone like
every late-night show every hacky stand
up like showgirls just became the go-to
you guys heard about the showgirls oh no
no one elf Anna yeah yeah yeah
let's keep going you remember elizabeth
berkley from Saved by the Bell
now she's all grown up and she's
bringing the same energy she brought to
the caffeine pills episode she's
recently made a peaceful wall no matter
what's happening in the scene whether
it's dancing dancing even harder I mean
come on that's on purpose like yeah
there's no way they do she doesn't get
to that intensity without like seven
takes of him being like that's how Paul
Verhoeven sounds sounds Dutch he's not
like an evil I just think gold matter
now that performance was gold another
reference so most of our audience
doesn't understand yeah this is a
commentary for no one nope just for our
own amusement yes
speaking whoa sorry or just anything
really so I don't you have the scenery
like a rabid dog then lick it afterwards
for good measure so long Larry follow or
insane journey from the seedy strip
clubs at the bottom to the bizarre
volcano Acrobat shows at the top with
only one person crazy dancing in her way
crystal Conners she's the top girl in
Vegas and the only thing she loves more
than the spotlight his dog food
I still love doggy Chow and the only
thing she loves more than dog food is
cocaine and the only thing she loves
more behind a camera too is the word not
her but everyone you're from the valley
darlin you're not fooling anybody
dee cause I just want a special shout
out the way John says the word cocaine
is one of the funniest things in cocaine
okay like it's just one of my favorite
deliveries yeah any time you guys see me
pitching movies know that it's because
someone does cocaine in them and I just
want John to say it again wow you played
the long con I was wondering why you
wrote that into the record ralph
scripted all the cocaine and now I get
it okay
that's good we did wreck-it Ralph right
I honestly don't write it I think we die
imagine oh yeah we did I know why yeah
we did
I remember the joke that got us some
trouble on that one oh yeah yes so we
definitely did wreck-it Ralph that's how
I remember nowadays is what joke we got
well actually there corrected on the
most we're always remember get out for
the serial joke yeah I will remember
anyway yeah yeah no relitigate that no
did you really get it every day we do
hey thanks fans yeah all right keep that
Vince most fans are cool yeah do you
like sex well not for long
thrill as showgirls teases you with
nudity
beat you over the head with it until
everyone has the appeal of raw meat in
this film that Rob's pubes of all their
mystery treat sex like a cheap commodity
to be bought and sold I'll fire for you
and depicts love as something that
happens between a man and a particularly
aggressive fish be careful that is a man
how sex works but it's exactly how you
get cool by the way
shout out to his pool yeah for the the
neon palm trees yeah nice nice touch
especially in the climate where he could
just put you know palm tree palm trees
he's he's really one of the peak 90s
just like characters in general he was
he him and Rob Lowe from Wayne's World
exam might be the same person really
great 90 sleaze bags in the movies is
the perfect haircut and they have the
well he's got the neon pool and he's got
the brick cell phone that we didn't
picture but yeah he's got the thing
that's like the the cinder block that
you unfold no very soft and then like
uses it to call back the guy that you
know you thought he thought was a dick
get back up here and just a small PSA
for you guys Twin Peaks having sex in a
pool or a hot tub it might be gross well
yeah it's it's counterintuitive because
it's not as anyways keep going yep look
it up play or don't bike up your T
Street and dance like no one's watching
you can't because this is even one of
the most campy shallow movies ever made
must be weird not having anybody
complain yet for it's a brilliant satire
of show business there's worse to her
more can't even comprehend I like a lot
of different champagnes but I always
stick with champagne mmm story
Elizabeth Boozer Glee but Gina Gershon
that 90s haircut and ron has Magic Mike
joel schumacher's Gotham
the shape of water and the lady on the
Internet
okay show me strip up to the streets
that's a later thank you thank you thank
you the only thing funnier than watching
showgirls watching with the isolated
audio how'd you guys find this TJ afford
to watch this if TJ is do I love that
they actually went back and loop to that
yeah TJ who is one of our to along with
Kevin well fantastic editing team yes
sent us
I believe this TJ sent us the isolated
audio because some movies when you when
you bring them into the editing software
a lot of times depending on how the file
structures etcetera you have the tracks
different you know all the audios on
different tracks and he said hey for
this one the way that it works out is
you can listen you can strip away the
music you can strip away the background
and you can just hear like the dialogue
and the Foley and he's like you have to
see this and he sent us a string out of
clips of the movie with no the only way
to what I've seen is once so it's like
there's no music it's just like yeah
none of the extras are actually making
noise they're all just yeah you hear
like clothing rustling sometimes it's
like that Star Wars without music clip
it any award ceremony yeah which is
amazing
Aurel not so I believe did that credit
to them amazing so but yeah so that was
a hundred percent of catch on their part
so good job TJ Kevin and good job on
editing by the way Kevin I don't know
who did the tracking on the Hal phases
but it's flawless yes perfect good job
at a single slip so yes a great great
editing job from our team as always on
this one because they did a great a
great week and Rob hoppy the graphics it
takes a village
let's see some deleted scenes and the
only thing she loves more than cocaine
is the word darlin darlin darlin darlin
darlin darlin
that's a mighty polite to retch you got
there darlin story jesse spasso Drew
Barrymore dodged a bullet
Marilyn Monroe Oh m'darlin Oh m'darlin
Clementine leaks the Hooters are not
what they seem
Alvin Ailey misshapen
dancer electric Boogaloo dirty dancing
very dirty Flashdance
and thanks how you fought it over seis
it's pronounced Versace actually the
most accurate pronunciation would be
Versace a so y'all are both wrong darlin
there you go very portable movie we well
actually the movie we well is at J yeah
yeah that's it
girls girls we did it because Fifty
Shades freed is coming out and I don't
know how highly requested this was but
it's like a classic bad movie so we
figured we might as well yeah it's
always one for us sometimes it's you
know three for the fans and that's that
this was not for the fans but sometimes
it's just like hey this is an
interesting thing that we have a
personal angle on that we know is not
gonna be a huge view getter but
something that would be fun it's a
little awkward to be watching it in the
office on loop you know for it was weird
sitting with you guys and watching
showgirls in our weird little writers
room oh you guys the old set up there
was no office so like I you have to edit
Game of Thrones in a big editing bullpen
with eight other editors and everyone in
the office walking by as I'm doing it so
I mean yes it was a figure doing a
monologue and these ladies are doing
things yeah exactly and like you know
the president the company's walking by
like what's going on I'm like I'm not
working yeah but I don't know this
movie's a curiosity it's worth I think
we're watching just on its own merits
just just to see it just to experience
the cultural flashpoint that was
showgirls yes yeah hopefully if you
weren't around we gave you a little
slice of what that time was like yeah
just what we like to do here on
wild times really really take you back
yeah a nice blast to the past
talk about a blast next week we will
also be blasting you with something a
little darker a little more mysterious
but also works well during the day yeah
yeah yeah you can watch it day or night
yeah yeah and I think it's gonna be a
good value uh-huh
good a good deal why maybe not one movie
maybe maybe right you get more
yeah maybe three maybe we'll get three
movies and the three of us right here
next week on honest trailer commentaries
Edie
[Music]
you